we've never done a project where we
could see
such a huge impact on the clients
so individuals who are faced with mental
health challenges or economic challenges
having them try to navigate all of these
disparate systems how do we
improve that process and that experience
ibm solution really allowed for
secured access to the data that's all
protected in our data center
from the cloud what the ibm product is
bringing to the team
an ability for them to really care
coordinate have a holistic view
and then be able to set goals and manage
their cases right in that technology
with watson in the cloud we can actually
engage and interact with our clients
anywhere at any time
we could really make a difference we
could not only serve this population
better
we could also save money while we're
doing it
this system can be used for any number
of individuals or cohorts of individuals
it is a blueprint for how we're going to
provide care
across the county bringing this
technology to government
is really revolutionizing and
transforming the way that government
does work
you